I think that the New York Jets are gonna
go ten and six I think the buffalo bills
are the most grossly overrated team in
the NFL everybody's body into the
hyperbole I am completely blown away by
people's belief that they're going to
the playoffs and they're gonna win nine
or ten games it's a five and 11 teen
they stink I feel it in a big way ten
and six and with that this sunday the
Jets go out and beat the cleveland
browns 19 to seven I recognize that I
put myself out there but I believe baby
I believe official prediction time guys
I think the Jets ride the momentum of
last week's win in second half and stun
the Indianapolis Colts the official
score of the game is 2621 New York Jets
I'm gonna go eagles 20 Jeff 16 puts my
feelings to go that route but that's uh
that's my official prediction I think
that the Jets go into Wembley 1914 thank
me tight I don't think there's made a
lot of scoring and so I think the Jets
prevail at a home 2210 jets over the
Redskins
I don't hedge I don't hedge but I'm
hedging meaning this is clearly the game
I'm most confused about unfortunately go
2716 Patriots so i just got done taping
another episode where i got to talk
about going 6 for 6 i'm not happy about
it because i hate the Patriots with all
my heart and soul and I'm a little bit
worried about the Raiders game coming up
this week so 747 is gonna be a challenge
because I'm not quite sure exactly
what's gonna happen a little bit of a
toss-up game but I hope you're making
money because I'm [ __ ] brilliant